[Music]
if you could have one do-over
[Music]
what would it be
you know even with everything we've been
through
nothing i feel like we went through
everything we went through
to get us where we are
or where we will be
i'll see you for color girl
i can assure you that whatever it is you
need to succeed we got you up why aren't
you married i'm just not right now my
dad said ain't nobody checking for
bitter ass black women anymore tell your
dad that black women aren't bitter
they're just tired of being expected to
settle for less her outfit saddle
phyllis
[Laughter]
like working with kids to be honest [ __ ]
them
but i'm trash too so
you know
i want you to go home and get you some
of that good burpee
actually i'm thinking about ending
things with lawrence i'm sorry what was
that we don't do anything i'm sorry for
ruining your birthday i bombed the
interview i'm almost done with my
business plan i'm just getting my [ __ ]
together i got a plan start the business
how about that
oh look i guess you're still single
couldn't find another [ __ ] to make your
toes tingles
[Music]
it doesn't matter what i do if i'm into
them then i'm too smothering well you
know i just wanted to know that you got
home safety that's all sex right away
lose interest wait to have sex flu is
interesting the point is you gotta [ __ ]
a lot of frogs to get a good frog that's
not the saying
or
anything
yeah i know that you and lawrence broke
up wait what why
because she cheated on him
i told him what we did was a mistake oh
so you [ __ ] up our [ __ ] for some
goddamn mistake
honestly i want to live by myself [ __ ]
where you ain't got no money i didn't
mean to come at you like that but a
[ __ ] try [ __ ]
you don't have enough money to move out
on your own i told daniel i'd only be
staying there a few weeks i'm sleeping
on the couch i know you can't keep
buying kelly not even a little bit
it's like you do so well and then you
don't
when's your last relationship i was in
one for five years and i cheated
he didn't deserve it i just kind of
messed up
i was honest
i'm not like mad anymore but i can't not
see her as a cheetah mm-hmm tell it chad
didn't you do the same thing easy did
yeah but she hulk she's not a hoe she
just did some oh [ __ ] man you're good
yeah i'm good too got a california king
all of myself no the [ __ ] never used to
make the bed i had to ignore the signs
that's my fault check
[Music]
[ __ ] i got like three out of sleep
let's tell what the hell is wrong with
you fry your face you bang them pants
one more time all the life is strange
talk to me blood me and i were just
about to go watch the bear bears cabbies
daddy
ah we use no sea word sweetheart it's a
blood house we did to turn the bag
i like that
you gonna do it with it mm-hmm what
about that you know i can't move in
though you're right and today it's all
about me
and today so hey i said me yeah and
today it's like it's gonna be about you
uh-huh and get it ready feed you
and get it ready
[ __ ] it
kelly
i'm disappointed we're better than this
you're going to be hot as [ __ ] ain't you
the property manager you need to fix
that [ __ ] it's 65 degrees but go off
what are you doing i faked an accent
when we met and now i have to commit
don't make it weird
darling please me isa d
i mean hey i'm
american kelly's british so that is a
fact
if you knew the end was coming
how would you make the most of your time
left
is there anything you would change
what legacy do you want to leave behind
[Music]
how would you want to be remembered
[Music]
you